The Japanese government has agreed to pay one billion yen,
equal to about 8.3 million U.S. dollars,
into a fund to support former South Korean comfort women.
These women were taken from their homes, and used as sex slaves by the Japanese military during World War II.
Japan also offered an official apology,
and if they follow through and pay what they pledged,
South Korea will see this matter irreversible resolved,
at least legally.
This seems like a huge step to mend marred relations between the two Asian nations,
but not everyone is supportive of this deal.
The reason many are upset, and that includes surviving victims,
is that they feel the deal was little more than diplomatic cover for Japan.
There is money coming directly from the Japanese government,
but it's not in the form of legal reparations.
If it were, Japan would be admitting that  their actions were illegal,
but they stopped short of that.
Instead, just offering an apology.
Japan also wants South Korea to take down a statue memorializing comfort women
that was erected outside of the Japanese Embassy in Seoul
Many see this as another way that Japan is trying to bury its past.
And if it sounds like Japan is strategic with the way they conduct their public apologies,
it's because they've had a lot of experience doing it.
Since the end of World War II,
numerous Japanese political officials have apologized for various atrocities
to different communities of people in a number of countries.
This includes apologies to Australian Prisoners of War,
American Prisoners of War,
Canadian Prisoners of War,
the people of Burma, the Philippines, Indonesia, China
and blanket apologies to all people who were affected by their brutality during World War II.
They have also apologized to the people of Korea in five different decades.
But for many, this is still not enough.
Partly because their track record of denial is just as long as their track record of apology.
They have on occasion denied certain massacres, calling them "fabrications".
And as recently as 2014,
they've denied that comfort women were forcibly abducted by members of the Japanese military.
Others feel their apologies don't go far enough.
That confidential documents outlining their involvement in war crimes should be officially released.
That Japanese history books should be amended.
And that Japan should admit, under international law, their responsibility.
But Japan will have more chances to apologize.
And next up, might be Taiwan.
On the heels of Japan's apologies to South Korea's comfort women,
Taiwan is demanding an apology to the women who were abducted from their country during World War II.
Women who were also used as military sex slaves.
That's something Japan has yet to admit.
It's been more than 70 years since Japan surrendered to end World War II,
but they might not ever be able to put their war crimes fully behind them.
And many people think they never should.
To see what other repercussions of war communities are forced to deal with,
watch this video
about how a town is using leftover bombs to build homes.
We see the explosions and troops on T.V..
War leaves behind scarred earth and communities
left to pick up the pieces, trying to rebuild the life they once knew.
And in some cases, using the remnants of war to do just that.
And as always, thanks for watching, and don't forget to subscribe.